while the president remained in
Washington over the weekend very snowy
he was ready and willing to do a deal
with the Democrats to reopen the
government Nancy Pelosi and her crew
left town but oh they talked a good game
why punish people who are applying for
food stamps because the president is
having a temper tantrum open government
first I hope they'll just do the right
thing reopen the government more border
security let's have at it but while
we're having that debate let's reopen
the government come on let's get down to
business here open up this government
tomorrow as I always say forget what
they say look at what they do
as Democratic leaders adjourned the
house on Friday more than 30 Democratic
members and their families needed to
catch a chartered flight bound for the
sunny shores of Puerto Rico
so while 800,000 government workers
remain on furlough these very concerned
Democrats were living the high life at a
beach resort in San Juan very nice the
trip came courtesy of 109 lobbyists from
Facebook Amazon various unions and
Microsoft you know the little people
well it was part of the Congressional
Hispanic Caucus is bold PAC retreat the
Democrats were purportedly there to
survey the damage of Hurricane Maria and
talk with various union groups now
remember that tidbit
now here's Senator Robert Menendez he's
taking a very personal interest in the
local recovery efforts looks like
instead of helping the hurricane victims
he's helping himself to a hurricane on
the rocks mm-hmm now let's face it this
is a liberal pack junket paid for by the
lobbyists so that congressmen and
Senators can frolic in the tropics with
celebrities yes the big congressional
getaway fell on the same weekend
wouldn't you know as Broadway megastar
lin-manuel Miranda brought his Tony
award-winning musical Hamilton to the
island with the original cast no less
well imagine the luck the media have
been tripping over themselves praising
Miranda for his tireless efforts to
bring Hamilton to Puerto Rico as a
fundraiser to support the Arts on the
islands a nice thing the plan was
to perform the musical for three weeks
smash success at the theater at the
University of Puerto Rico now there's a
really interesting backstory get that
got lost in all the gauzy coverage it's
the alma mater of Lynne Manuel's father
the Miranda family charity raised a
million dollars to restore and upgrade
the storm-ravaged theater good stuff but
this led to a shutdown of a different
sort it turns out the University of
Puerto Rico is roiled by Union protests
and one of those unions sent a letter to
Miranda's father the letter ended up
saying there are real problems at the
University of Puerto Rico and we want to
advise bad things protests can happen
around your production now lin-manuel
Miranda has been all for protest seeing
his family of long supported left-wing
causes and he's even mind his Hamilton
score for protest songs don't stop don't
give up these families united well the
New York Times quote some students at
the University of Puerto Rico who were
less than thrilled that Hamilton would
be coming to campus trying to figure
this out one said quote the only artists
and people that benefit from Hamilton
are the elite white North American
settlers the rich bourgeoisie and those
who actively participate and aspire to
become oppressors as a latin person he
should be more conscious of who Hamilton
was he's glorifying a person that
represents oppression he could have made
a show about Harriet Tubman well in
addition to the Union group students
were also threatening to protest the
production on campus so how did mr.
they're not taken away my shot react in
the face of the leftist threats well
sadly he caved to the pressure and moved
the production to an Arts Center off
campus Miranda gave in to mob rule he
also missed a huge opportunity with the
world
looking on no less to challenge and
educate the liberal forces undermining
free speech on campus even art that
pretty much supports their agenda
if these College nuts are emboldened
enough to go after their favorite son
who just gave him a million bucks to
rebuild their theater what can other
performers expect and Lynn what would
Hamilton have done it was an ovation
right no no cathartic after so much pain
the ultimate tribute the Puerto Rico's
resiliency well Miranda never looked
back the whole controversy in the entire
episode in capitulations these leftist
coups was lost in a swirl of celebrity
and glamour just the way the left likes
it
Oh in some of those 30-plus visiting
Democrats were right there applauding
along in the audience Sunday night but
poor babies they had to buy their own
Hamilton tickets according to reports
but don't worry they got to attend an
after-party with the cast for free
courtesy of the Latino victory is a
liberal pack you see the elites always
stick together I bet they thought they
were in the room where it happened even
if they weren't and that's the angle